[Music]
let's see if I can punch through a voice
kind of been fighting it but I'm back
what up LEF koe man the left go showing
Bert to my left
what's that let go feeling good man
feeling good we've been traveling a lot
yeah it does it does things to your
voice Oh
ports that recycled air on the airport
yeah it's it's not good I haven't had
the chance to like not talk for two days
so if I push through I can get a little
bit of a normal voice like this but then
I'm like what damage am i doing beyond
that we'll find out Celine Dion doesn't
speak between performances really she's
just straight up she gives you her two
hours she's magnificent and then she
just doesn't talk I'm sure she's texting
her it has a whiteboard which carries
I've been called the Celine Dion of
Bleacher I've heard that yeah D the P is
coming together ditch the playbook we're
getting ready it's gonna be Erin the
Wednesday before the first game of the
year so September 5th Thursday
bears-packers was the first game of the
year that Wednesday our first episode is
going to come out it's gonna be every
other week most of the season is shot
it's going well but I think you guys are
really gonna enjoy it and David's been
in the Edit Bay go and crazy with
Julianne so I'm excited I haven't been
going crazy and it's been a very
pleasant edit and honestly like the
notes from other folks in bleacher
report that have seen the episodes are
very excited about it as we are I think
you guys are gonna like it it's taking
things that that kind of would be here
with the 33% taking them to another
level hope you guys enjoyed your s LFL
excuse me your LF GL girafft let's
[ __ ] go League we had ours on
Thursday 92 leagues for the let's the LF
GL the left go fantasy gridiron leak we
were both drafting how did you do did
you take andrew luck no I did not I have
two fantastic quarterbacks and I didn't
feel like I was waiting too long on
either of them I have both Russell
Wilson which I'm very excited yeah my
first two picks by the way I have Ross
Wilson to OD in that league
I have Michael Thomas and God now I
can't forget anyone right no I should've
was a wide receiver no I had to write
James Connor and Michael Thomas were my
two first supersolid which I'm very I'm
very happy with my team I've Calvin
Ridley I've learned when I talk to
people I will hear your first two picks
and then I completely lose interest and
I've Drew Brees I mean they're like like
and then in the seventh round I got
hunter Henry I'm like bro I'm so out
alright I texted you that in the sixth
round I took Darius guys and you
actually got pretty jacked up yeah well
you know I like the guy
we love Darius guys around maybe
happening with Darius guys but the draft
is fun I drafted with my buddy my home
buddies last night and all of the mocks
the 500 mocks that I did it finally for
the first year felt worth it really
where I got done how many did you
actually do because you say 500 I know
it's kind of a joke I'm I don't think
I'm exaggerating
wait I'm telling you that on the sleeper
app you can crank out like 20 in an hour
oh my god that's incredible like it was
bad but it's the first year or ever
where I got done that League and I
looked at my fiancee and I said holy
crap that was I've really enjoyed that I
got I got Hopkins and Tyree kill like
let's go dude alright so I'm Way too
excited fantasy that was not great so
good luck to your team's again we're
gonna play the playoffs start in week 13
for the LF GL the winner of the entire
super league lfg l will come on this
podcast this upcoming Thursday podcast I
am going to do my official predictions
for the season I know who I'm putting in
the playoffs for the AFC I had a moment
of clarity this morning in the shower
everything came into perspective I am
locked and loaded for my AFC am I gonna
be surprised by any of the picks a few
surprises feel good about him like NFC I
can't figure out the south and the north
okay they're too bunched out but I'll
figure it out by Thursday
MVP all that stuff bets and I'm hoping
and all signs are pointing to we are
going to call the co-hosts that are
gonna be a part of this show one is
locked in
crossed all together but I'm feeling
good I'm excited to let you guys know
who you're gonna be talking to your me
listening to all year and talking to on
social media but it's all coming
together men I'm sitting there I got all
my notebooks I'm building to take notes
this season I got my structure my
schedules D the P ditch the play books
ready to go we're ready man hey fellas
happening yeah you're you're in the the
pre week one glow right now and
something has already happened Andrew
Luck Saturday night what what happened
we're gonna do a little clock now and
then I have my seven big takeaways from
preseason week three which is always the
big preseason week in the NFL that I'm
gonna share after this boat Saturday
night where were you this is how
everyone should be talking about Andrew
Luck right now
everyone's on line go it's the craziest
news story ever I mean the owner of the
Patriots literally got busted in a in a
place down in Florida at a massage
parlor but this is the craziest thing
that's ever happened in the world I mean
literally a patriot had his house broken
into so the police showed up and found
Coca now he's in trouble but this is the
craziest thing in the world I mean
there's a million Patriot stories I put
above this but where were you on
Saturday night oh I wasn't you find I
was putting my daughter to bed and when
I'm putting my daughter to bed I try not
to have my phone with me because even
the glow of a notification or a text or
something can sort of brighten up the
room and can you know any any excuse for
her to wake up and the ho what's going
on there's bright lights so I try to
keep it completely dark but of course I
forgot it was sitting on the night table
next night and then I got to sleeper
apps and to bleacher report
notifications and then a text and then I
think you texted me back and it was just
it was like Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing like it was a Vegas slot
machine I was like god dammit now I had
to check this and so I checked it and
then I said to my two-year-old who
doesn't know who Andrew Luck is I said
like can you believe Andrew Luck retired
29 years old that's pretty crazy and she
said hey that's what you said so so that
was a strong take there were a lot of
strong takes on Twitter but none
stronger than I so in NFL season a
little bit insight of Who I am as a
person to maintain my relationship I
have to give up certain days and nights
for the relationship
I am entering football world Sunday
through Thursday night I don't exist
Sunday Monday Thursday I'm watching
football Tuesday I'm getting ready for
the podcast Wednesday I'm making my
picks I am and I am NOT hanging out I'm
not doing dinners like people like hey
you want to get a drink
nope can't do it you're studying you're
free on Friday and Saturday so I have
made a deal with my fiance that date
night is untouchable mm-hmm we had to be
in DC on Friday night for a shoot so
Saturday was untouchable I am on a
rooftop I am eating a steak my phone is
under the table I have it like you it's
either in my pocket or it's like
facedown on a plant you know what I mean
like just keep it away from me I'm not
gonna forget my phone and in the middle
of the dinner fiance goes to the
bathroom and of course you're like all
right this is my two-minute window I
look at my phone and then turn it off
and I go and I turn it over and just so
many notifications slide and I I am
cramming I'm like trying to read
everything and as she comes back I turn
it and turned down and I'm like she
doesn't know who Andrew Luck is she has
no idea what's going on and I can't talk
about it and it's like it's like your
friend had a sleepover for tenant with
like 10 kids with the class and you
weren't allowed to go your phone because
I'm like there is so much [ __ ] going
down on social media right now and I
can't be a part of it but I'm sure that
Colts fans wishes they had some time to
digest sure yeah I mean just from the
reaction there's there's a number of
ways to talk about this I think the
first thing I do want to talk about is
the fans booing because I thought me and
you actually had a conversation in the
car on the way to DC that wasn't even
about this but it touches on it mm-hmm
large groups of humans suck yeah in
general large groups of humans that
believe in anything are the worst places
to be and we literally spent hour car
ride going what is a large group of
humans that we actually think are okay
and we ended on
Buddhists also I've been thinking about
this more people who work at zoos excuse
I imagine if you add them up there's
hundreds of thousands or maybe millions
of people who work at zoos they all seem
to be pretty cool it means they're all
like they put they put animals over
people they're dedicating their life to
like feeding pandas and like you know
helping helping a red panda you know
climb a tree I don't know I would say
that's an incredible take and I support
it because you know what people that
hold sloths
probably get along whether you think
they're gonna be bad yeah they're
awesome but I would say towards the
bottom is sports fans sport any Jews
arts fans bottom of sports fans is
people that sit all the way through a
preseason football game so I believe
that this is sort of what's also to be
expected and I want to say this really
quick too as a Philadelphia sports fan
who for the longest time has been
defined by the actions of sports fans
that I don't even know I did not throw
batteries at JD Drew I did not throw
snowballs it's a good tape you might
have been there I did not do those ha I
did not cheer Michael Irvin getting
concussed and I know that we need to
talk about this so fans can go can do
better but I've always found to cop out
to [ __ ] on fan bases that react
gutturally to stuff like this when news
spreads on cellphones at public events
like this people are talking and it's so
if the person that sits at a preseason
football game all the way through if
they're supposed to gain clarity by
talking to another human but the only
human they talk to is another person
that sits all the way through a
preseason football game these people are
not getting clarity these people are
getting enraged because they're sitting
there going I just spent all my money on
season tickets it's the first thing now
it is incredible to me because my friend
said this that if this was a wrestling
match they would have the sense to go
one more match one norm like I actually
trust WWE fans because they're in on the
storylines then the NFL fan who's
sitting there being like it's Super Bowl
or bust
right but one of those is scripted one
of them is not sorry if I'm breaking
kayfabe for the first time a thousand
percent wrestling fans but it is funny
to me that wrestling fans would go NFL
fans don't have that and I but I
understand it so I'm not I don't jump on
the whole anti Indianapolis fan stuff I
think if they had a parade tomorrow
they'd all show up if we go back to June
when klay Thompson injured himself and
we thought that the Raptors fans were
cheering for it but if Rockets oh is the
rocket no I think it was the and if you
watch it and you see the the Raptors and
the Warriors players they're like hey
everyone stop stop cheering for an
injury that's a horrible but if you
watch it in real time you just think
that there was a turnover that was
happening Kyle Lowry had stolen the ball
I believe and was on his way down to
score and it was a very big bucket they
were cheering for that and they were
booing for like some some they hated the
Warriors I don't think they were
cheering for an injury don't think they
were booing klay Thompson for getting
injured but the narrative became oh
these fans are really you know being
real jerks right now we all want like I
always say that people like JJ Watt are
not normal people like Tom Brady are not
normal yet we talk about them like
they're the normal athletes the perfect
living the life's only eating what
you're supposed to like they're not
normal what's normal is the everyday NFL
player that sometimes workout it's kind
of a guy but we talked about that and
with fans we expect everyone to be
Wimbledon oh but the true thing is is
that if my team was in the Super Bowl I
played your team in the Super Bowl and
Brandon cooks got hurt and my first
reaction was [ __ ] this is helping us and
then I went oh don't do that
but my first reaction was this is
helping my team yeah it's a now oz ative
and and and because of that because
you're so into it you know what I mean
you're thinking about so I don't but
Mona and I don't chastise them at all
because I think it's normal if they
would have applauded then we would be
applauding them but it is interesting to
me that the only three people that came
out disparaging Andrew Luck for quitting
on his team two weeks before was Dan
dockets Doug Gottlieb and OJ Simpson
an incredible trio if you were to ask
who are the if you could go to dinner
for four with three other people this is
right there towards the bottom of the
list Doug Gottlieb dandaka chin OJ
Simpson Gottlieb got raked for his joy
Aikman destroyed him yeah I mean one
just came out and said oh I guess that's
how you stay on fs1 all right did you
see what uh what my man Doug Baldwin
said no it was it was a really great
tweet he wrote how dare Luck not
sacrifice his body for my entertainment
who cares if your shoulder is too messed
up to pick up your child who cares if
your knees are too messed up to play
with your kids who cares about your
quality of your life what about the
quality of my Sunday's strong take from
Doug Baldwin look I heard Simmons
talking about this where he was saying
that the correct response actually is to
say this is kind of shitty like it's
okay to say it's a little bit [ __ ] up
that he's leaving the team two weeks
before but in the world we are right now
of thinking about the humans we've never
thought more about humans as athletes as
we do now uninterrupted their whole
thing is more than an athlete we have
the players Tribune where people get to
speak for themselves
I literally come on here and say this
the players podcast and I fight for
players all the time where we are as an
ideology with covering sports we've
never cared more about these human
beings than we do right now compared to
the past
there was a one of the 34 30s was about
Houston Oilers it may have been a
football life where there was one season
where all these distractions happened
and one of the storylines that happened
was one of the players missed the game
for the birth of his kids this is early
90s and was chastised by the media for
not caring as much that happens in
baseball all the time
but now in our society it's completely
different and so in a weird way Andrew
Luck is part of the switch from being
very tribal and caring about teams to
now if you ever say anything about
letting down teams or being whatever it
if you are going against the human
rights or health or longevity it's
immediately seen as wrong I'm not saying
it's right I'm just saying it's
interesting to look at that switch
we've turned like that definitely with
with Andrew Luck than narrative I think
this this retirement will become the
poster incident for people describing
the new era of how we think about
players and we think about mental health
and we think about physical health Chris
Borland may have been the first who was
the San Francisco 49ers linebacker that
had a concussions and after like one
great year or two great years he called
it after - yeah I'm not saying he's the
first person to reduce the Crilley
hussion retire early guy but what were
you saying well I mean Barry Sanders
retired 20 years Robert Smith retired
when he was like 28 remember how good he
was to go back to like go to Harvard or
something like that I mean a lot of guys
have retired very early and we go huh I
guess good for you
and I actually interestingly enough Rob
Gronk is also 29 years old the same same
age as Andrew Luck no one said oh man
come on
you'll be another five years in you they
reference between those two was we had
heard through the media for three years
Gronk really isn't enjoying himself
krunk's really hurt right now blurgh
time because meas every time he touches
the walk he he had braces on every
single Bend of his body my elbow with
Andrew Luck I think part of what made us
such a shock is the Colts have been
insanely secretive about him for the
last three years
remember when he missed that entire
season we didn't know that he was gonna
miss that entire season when he played
we didn't know he was gonna play like
everything has been in secrecy and in
doubt so there's been we don't know
where he was and because it was really
to save face for the Colts so that they
could still sell season tickets under
the guise that he was gonna play but I
think in the end it really hurt Andrew
Luck because we never knew the truth of
how hurt he was over this time right and
I think that's a factor in the - do you
know who the Commissioner of the XFL is
yes he's not going what her luck I just
I really I really enjoyed that as a as a
possible conspiracy theory like one
extra peg in this story if I was a Colts
fan though I would be I would be a
little pissed and I'd be a little upset
mhm and I I think you can appreciate
Andrew Luck for what he gave you but I
think you could also look around the NFL
and go okay Texans are gonna take a step
back we had the Patriots we got the
Chiefs but like we're really like the
third team in the AF
we we finally have the offensive line
like the thing that's so crushing he had
no help for so long and now all the help
is here
and he finally got the GM and he finally
got a wide receiving core with Paris
Campbell and Devin Funchess and T Y
Hilton and he finally got an offensive
lineman's never had I mean when I look
at Andrew Luck I think what's really
incredible is you see what he's done
this with his offensive line allowed a
hundred sacks in the first three seasons
he never he had one 1,000 yard runner in
his seven seasons and it was a thousand
and 25 barely made at Frank Gore he
averaged three point nine yards a carry
so here's a guy that had no offensive
line he really only had T Y Hilton and
then his running backs he finally has
Marlin Mac everything's coming together
he's got an all-pro rookie at linebacker
they didn't have a defense the entire
time and he finally has it and now his
body breaks down that's also what's so
crushing to me oh it's totally crushing
and it just goes to show that this was
much more than just a simple decision
for him because if it was if he was
looking down the barrel of another year
where he was gonna get sacked 48 times
in 16 weeks maybe that's where he says
you know what screw this I'm retiring
but if it's looking like he's got the
team around him you know they're they're
totally in contention for a possible AFC
championship type berth you know totally
I think they're the favorites to win the
the AFC South this year you are now
they're the biggest Thunder dry with
luck they would have been so if he's got
all those pieces together and he still
retires we know how how heavily this
must have been weighing on him I knew
that it was set in stone by listening to
all of the coaches talk and also knowing
who Andrew Luck is Andrew Luck is never
going to be that athlete that comes in
and does something spontaneously Andrew
Luck is maybe the one quarterback that
would sit in a dark room and meditate
mm-hmm that would sit in a room and
really think about his decision the
other thing that I believe you look at
we could have seen this coming with
Andrew Luck if we
realized what is about to becoming 17
days from recording this Andrew Luck is
turning 30 years old hmm he is currently
29 and a lot of people make a lot of
turning 30 we see this all the time
I'm sure 30 years old was a big birthday
for you and everybody comes up and says
wow it feels as though your life is
changing I got engaged at 29 a lot of
major life events happen at that and
this is something that goes back in
history history that Andrew Luck I'm
sure has paid attention to you look at
Jeff besos Jeff besos was somebody that
was working at like a bank he had a de
sha and he left to found Amazon in his
garage
a few months before his 30th birthday a
very successful man in finance that said
I'm not doing what I want I need to
follow my passion okay
Charlie Munger who many people believe
is one of the shrewdest investors that's
ever been he was you know at a law firm
making very good money wife kids right
before his 30th birthday got divorced
left started his own thing there's a lot
of people in history that have
incredible potential that were already
really successful at something that when
they hit that point begin to question
everything and think I need more Andrew
Luck by all accounts is one of the most
intelligent humans and worldly humans
that have ever played the position of
quarterback and so really him turning 30
in a few weeks all of this makes sense
sitting in a training room for four
years rehabbing a body that we all know
is being pieced mailed together and that
we're just trying to get through for
record books
and four pieces of paper and four stats
now Super Bowls a whole nother thing but
in his mind he's got an entire life to
live and he is worldly enough to factor
in these things and I really think the
fact that
about to turn 30 is probably pushing him
in that direction I respect that I've
always thought about that as yeah I'm
sure everyone out there that that isn't
a mega mega millionaire like me has
thought about the amount of money that
it would take for you to just be like oh
great now I can just live my life for
the rest of my life and I can just buy a
house somewhere and just hang out and
raise my child and just live on interest
and be able to go on trips and clearly
Andrew Luck has has reached that that
number and I wonder actually and this is
this is gonna sound facetious but I
swear it's a true point I wonder if he
had played his whole career in either
San Francisco or in New York City if you
would have a different number in mind
right just in terms of the amount of
wealth he'd be surrounded by right if he
lives in Indiana you know having 25
million dollars in the bank is a very
different thing than having 25 million
dollars in the bank in Manhattan sure in
terms of the lifestyle he's not gonna
stay there but you're talking about
having saved money to this I'm saying
the sort of people he's hobnobbing with
if you're you know if you're Derek Jeter
you're hobnobbing with a very different
crowd than if you are Andrew Luck for
your athletic career and I just wonder
if maybe you know 25 million in Indiana
maybe in New York he says you know what
I will stick this out for the remainder
of my 58 million dollar contract cause I
want to get that in the bank but as
you've noted Andrew Luck very
intelligent guy probably has some really
strong investments going
I am positive he's going to continue
earning money in some capacity at sure
he's even maybe it'll be broadcasting
maybe it'll be coaching I don't know
tour guides maybe he'll be a Himalayan
tour guide yeah we know or maybe he'll
do Civil War reenactments he could be
the highest-paid civil war re-enactor in
American history my only disagreement
with you in terms of the city is I think
what determined this with Andrew Luck
was the lack of support he got and what
it did to him physically and I think the
way that I'm always gonna remember
Andrew Luck is realizing that football
has officially changed I believe that
Andrew Luck is the figurehead of how we
look at football players it happened
right at a turning point of the league
and what I mean by that is this Andrew
Luck is the poster child of how we all
want quarterbacks to play the position
but what we know is
it's a little bit too reckless we won
our quarterbacks to be throwing while
there's defensive linemen draped on his
left arm and possibly pulling down his
neck we want him running over a safety
to try and get the first yard first down
yardage that was Andrew Luck Andrew Luck
is the guy that we used to carson wentz
to go protect yourself and get out of
bounds
don't be Andrew Luck Andrew Luck played
the way that I've always wanted my
quarterback to play I wanted him to play
like a fullback with the arm of a cannon
and that's what Andrew Luck was he got
sacked a hundred times in the first
three seasons he had he had one running
back that cross a thousand yards just
barely was Frank Gore he really had T Y
Hilton and that was it
that man won more games and that team
ever should have
and it was by sheer will and I think
what's really unfortunate is what
happened in 2015 to him physically and
then what the league realized 2015 he
lacerates his kidney and then he misses
the entire next season 2015 the movie
concussion came out and we could talk
about whether or not it was a good movie
or what the impact was but at that point
is when the NFL and the public said we
need to care about player safety players
began retiring very early like Chris
Borland coaches were having to come out
and talk about practices and all this
and protecting it was a league issue and
right in the middle of it before
concussion and after decision BC and AD
was the career of Andrew Luck right in
the middle of Andrew Luck's career we
started caring about player safety but
it was already too late and that's what
I'll always remember about Andrew Luck
he was the last guy that's going to play
the quarterback position the way it's
truly meant to be played we've had a lot
of guys that we're gonna get tastes of
it we've already seen the end of Carson
Wentz Cam Newton sometimes puts himself
out there but he didn't go as hard as
Andrew Luck we've had guys play through
injuries and Tom Brady stuff but nobody
is played with the physicality
Andrew Luck and I believe he played
during the last generation of us go and
I love this kind of stuff and from now
on it's like Andrew Luck will be the
example of why we can't do it anymore
it's interesting that the way you're
describing luck is almost exactly the
way in 2012 I was describing rg3 right
the guy drafted right after luck where
he had these electrifying runs and we're
watching it like this guy plays the
position oh my god he doesn't care if he
gets tackled over the middle this guy's
gonna run for an extra six or seven
yards every time he can and you start
wondering as a sports fan I remember
even having this discussion with a
Redskins fan friend of mine back in 2012
would you rather have five years of
brilliant rg3 or 15 years of maybe a
slightly less you know thrilling Kirk
Cousins for example and it's a difficult
decision because we now know with Andrew
Luck like in order to get the the
version of Andrew Luck that we've all
wanted we get six or seven seasons of it
unfortunately and maybe if he had played
a different way or if he had been
brought up from middle school in high
school to play a different way or to
absorb contact a different way or to get
rid of the ball rather than trying to
scrunch forward for that third and two
maybe we he does get to play for 15 or
17 years like Phil Rivers the 2012 draft
is a bizarro world for quarterbacks when
you think about the difficult situations
we put these guys in ok Andrew Luck
Ryan Gregson did a very poor job of
building that team he's become the fall
guy in this entire thing Andrew Luck
thrown out there rain or shine healthier
not healthy with no offensive line and
no support staff gets hurt retires early
rg3 after an incredible rookie season
thrown out there on a sloppy field
already hurt hurts his leg never the
same becomes a journeyman backup the
third quarterback taking that draft in
the top 15 Ryan Tannehill again thrown
out there has been hurt off and on
throughout his entire career runs a lot
takes hits hurt the guys taken in the
third round and afterwards Russell
Wilson protected Nick Foles nice low
burn Kirk Cousins in that same draft
right so you look at the three
quarterbacks taken in the top 15
luck rg3 Tannehill you look at the guys
taken after the third round
Russell Wilson Nick Foles Kirk Cousins I
would argue that the later three were
treated like the franchise quarterback
well also because the Redskins they
traded up to get our g3 and they gave up
a king's ransom of potential draft picks
over the next few years and I remember a
reading I think it was a bill Barnwell
piece who broke down exactly how much
value five years later oh my grams were
able to extract from the five seven
whatever first-round picks that they got
for the RG three and it then starts
making me think about Peyton Manning the
the Colts were willing to give up Peyton
Manning because they were like I would
rather give up our legend Peyton Manning
for 15 years of Andrew Luck yes if you
attract them that was the debate if you
told them that it was six years of
Andrew Luck then they would say let's
roll the dice and get three or four
years of well I was six years as a
starter seven years in the league yeah
if you had told them all right it's
either Peyton Manning for four more
years or Andrew Luck for seven they
clearly would have kept Peyton Manning
and maybe they could have flipped that
number one overall pick for half a dozen
new offensive tackles and a new you know
cuz that was also that was also one of
the last trap well we've seen it with
Carson Wentz and Jared Goff both those
teams traded up to get those guys and
gave up a lot but they did not give up
as much as Washington and and what
Washington did for rg3 that was a year
where you could have gotten the King of
Kings ransom teams don't trade that much
anymore but this was back in 2012 saying
when Peyton Manning was coming off those
neck surgeries we didn't know if he was
gonna be good but we saw him in Denver
and he was damn good for three more
years Peyton Manning has a crippling
possibly career to fighting neck injury
playing for Indianapolis Andrew Luck
unable to go after seven years maybe
we'll start realizing that contact on
turf might not be great for all
positions a lot more give on grass the
u.s. women's soccer team talks about
this they end up getting forced to play
on turf and all these international
tournament and they're like no we want
to play on grass it's a totally
different thing one of the themes of
this podcast is grass not turf okay
because the best soccer players in the
world not even just women like Messi
Ronaldo it's in their contract there now
to play on the turf and so Peyton
Manning and Andrew Luck it ain't that
forgiving right and I am for all the
people there that are saying
this was a waste I would say that you
guys did not appreciate Andrew Luck
enough when he was there as I've said
before I don't know if I've enjoyed
anyone playing in the position more than
Andrew Luck the seven years he gave us
the comeback against Kansas City so many
of the times he lost in the playoffs the
team shouldn't have even been there the
year that they got blown out by the
Patriots in the AFC championship game
they upset I think it was Peyton
Manning's Broncos just to get in that
situation I think what's really
incredible was when you look back at the
injury that started this that 2015
injury the game in which he got it when
he when he woke up and he was peeing
blood and he had a lacerated kidney and
a torn AB muscle you know who was
against can't remember Peyton Manning's
Broncos mm-hmm so think about that that
all of the major injuries started in the
in his effort to unseat and beat the man
and the shadow that he was trying to
replace there is something beautiful
about Andrew Luck's career I am NOT
gonna sit here and it's changing who I'm
picking for the AFC South that's fine
and part of the reason that everyone's
coming out to support Andrew Luck is
because the media supports people that
are good to the media and Andrew Luck
has been one of the best to the media in
all circumstances but I am NOT gonna sit
here and say what could have been with
Andrew Luck Andrew Luck in my opinion
it's not a Hall of Fame career and
that's okay but in my mind Andrew Luck
had an incredible 6 to 7 yards span and
a 6 to 7 year span whenever we have a
young quarterback as Sam darn 'old has a
big year this year and Baker Mayfield
continues to make runs every time that
we see most touchdowns through the first
two years LOX names gonna be there every
time that we see most wins in the first
two years Luck's names gonna be there he
was on the trajectory but I am NOT gonna
sit here and say what could have should
have but coulda shoulda woulda
I thought Andrew Luck's first seven
years of his career he has earned the
right to say peace out
he got no [ __ ] hell everybody doubted
him and every time he lost a big game in
the playoffs and people blamed him
I would get furious they shouldn't have
even been in that situation but they
were only there because of Andrew Luck
so Andrew Luck can do whatever he wants
I applaud him i but also Colts fans it's
okay to be pissed it is you you just got
broken up with and it's shocking because
it's right before the wedding
and you're gonna realize in a year from
now that wedding wasn't gonna work out
and I'll tell you what maybe Jacobi
percent is fantastic and I think
everyone around here would love it if
Jacobi Brissette was awesome I'm gonna
say this the Colts are gonna rally
around Jacobi Brissette I still believe
that they're gonna be an eight or nine
win team mainly because I thought they
would have been a 12 win team with
Andrew Luck right that's about four but
eight or nine wins with Jacobi per set
they are going to be in the playoff hunt
the entire year I think the thing that
excites me the most about Jacobi rosette
is when Andrew Luck came back he said he
was actually a little bit jealous of
Jacobi because he has such a good
relationship with the team I look at the
comments of t-y Hilton I look at where
he said I love Andrew Luck I'm
dedicating this season to him the Colts
are gonna be good
but I think what sums up who Andrew Luck
is a person the most is that when he
decided he went to the coach and the
coach said to him from Frank Reich if
Andrews not there we got to move on we
got it to name Jacobi the guy and we got
to go forward and Andrew Luck responded
isn't that what's great about the game
Andrew Luck more than any athlete maybe
Kirk Cousins he understands mortality
and he understands what's temporary I
could see Kirk Cousins doing this in a
few years too by the way
reaching a point where he's like I have
more than enough my money totally I
might not win a Super Bowl but that's
okay totally huh but the fact that
Andrew is going to move on and the fact
that he is content I'm upset that the
moment when he wanted to deliver it was
taken from him but at the same point
that's the NFL man but I I applaud
Andrew Luck it's been a joy to watch him
he'll always be one of the most
underappreciated quarterbacks because he
came and Peyton Manning
shadow and he was deemed the next great
thing and I thought that I thought every
year of his career except for maybe one
not including the injuries he was a
top-five quarterback every single year I
look forward to describing this to let's
say my grandchild or something when
they're looking at hey man like who are
the best quarterbacks of your era and
they're looking at the numbers Peyton
Manning and Drew Brees and Tom Brady
it's like here's who's
critically-acclaimed career you might
not think of and in terms of the number
of playoff wins or total touchdowns or
what else oh [ __ ] okay let me calm down
the whole they're only a Hall of Fame
quarterback he's not a Hall of Fame
quarterback unfortunately but like the
total passing yard statistic right and
how like Eli is gonna be top six
all-time when it's all said and done
call me crazy
I'm here for a good time not always a
long time I care about if you're a
top-five quarterback for six to seven
years you're playing not the fact that
you are a top 15 quarterback for the 15
years you played I'm trying to win Super
Bowls I'm trying to have special seasons
I don't always need the longevity Tom
Brady is incredible because not only has
he been longevity but he's also been
like top five top ten every year and
performing under the clutches of moments
Frank Gore has played for a very long
time and I know that everybody wants to
write a love song to Frank Gore all the
time but there has not have been a
single season where he's been a top five
running back not a single season but he
keeps churning but Terrell Davis goes
into the Hall of Fame because he played
for six years and three of them he was
the number one running back in the NFL
and three others he was top five yeah
and so the NFL is not made to be played
for this long we're just spoiled right
now with Brees and Brady and Ben and Eli
and Philip Rivers we're like the magic
sauce has come because those are the
quarterbacks that have threw the ball
away on third and long and didn't take
the sacks and blame their offensive line
and got in arguments with the media that
it's protect me Andrew Luck said don't
protect me I'll go in there and get
lacked with this nonsense with Trent
Richardson behind me with an offensive
line of also-rans
and one wide receiver that misses seven
games a year god bless him I just
[ __ ] love interlock he seemed to yeah
I don't know a lot of stuff that I it
was it was incredible
it was I've never seen news happen like
this I do not get angry at Adam Schefter
for breaking it you got to break it why
would you get mad at and who's Matlock
there a lot of people got mad after I
mean you have seen what you did not do
like she just not share it with the
people I guess it's information exactly
but a happy birthday to Andrew Luck
alright so I have seven takeaways from
preseason Week three so excited for you
guys to hear the co-hosts are but first
one quarterbacks of the future mm-hmm
and they're unlikely people as everybody
and I want you to pick holes in this and
ask follow-up questions as everybody was
focusing on the crowd booing Andrew Luck
and what are the Colts gonna do and can
Jacoby percent do this I watched the
game the next day and said are you guys
seeing that the next franchise
quarterback for the Colts might be on
the team right now and it's not jacobi
percent Chad swag Kelly looked
phenomenal granted it was against a lot
of the number twos of the Bears but I'm
just saying that he looks like a
different player compared to his rookie
season the arm strength was unbelievable
he had three or four plays in that game
that were luck esque
breaking out of sacks throwing frozen
ropes on a dime he does look like one of
these guys that's real tough to bring
down I'm just saying you guys everybody
was focused on luck and Brissette and
Chuck Pagano and all these moments
returning to Indy I'm just saying watch
out the future of the Colts might be
with Chad swag Kelly and you missed it I
don't think I mean real Colts fans I'm
sure we're very eager to watch that next
game and say like how is this team gonna
look - Andrew Luck and
fact is you know if if Chad Kelly can
bring them to the promised land or
Jacoby Brissette comes out and you know
let's say they're four and one at the
end of five weeks maybe they're very
excited and you know we get to wish
Andrew Luck a very successful retirement
it's a lot easier it's an easier pill to
swallow
I don't think Chad Kelly is playing this
season I think it's the Jacoby pre-set
season
I'm just saying of the future everyone's
talking about oh but if they finish
eight and eight nine and seven they're
gonna be picking around 15 which doesn't
let them go after the treble Laurence's
or the to a tongue of I Louis and I say
okay but I'm saying you might have this
steel of like a guy making no money in
Chad Kelly that if he develops and
everyone thought he was arguably one the
most talented quarterbacks in a draft
loaded with quarterbacks when he came
out Baker
Rosen Sam Allen Lamar take a look on the
bench you might get a guy second left Co
take away from preseason week three the
Saints quarterback of the future is also
on the roster and it's not Teddy
Bridgewater oh I love Taysom Taysom Hill
is the guy go to youtube go to the NFL
counts just watch the long form
highlights of that game and tell me one
play by Taysom Hill that doesn't look
like the starter and the NFL that he
should be true Brees is gonna play this
year his contract is coming up soon I'm
just letting you know that the way that
Sean Payton can develop this offense
with Michael Thomas and Alvin Kamara and
Taysom Hill what a physic is the offense
of the future and I am willing to say
right now that I believe that the
quarterback that replaces Drew Brees
should be Taysom Hill he is no longer
just a gadget guy and also if the gadget
guy improves the running game because
he's a threat to keep it
it ain't a gadget guy if we're willing
to do this with Kyler if we're willing
to do this with Lamar if we're willing
to do this with Josh Allen I believe
that Taysom Hill is as good if not
better of an athlete than the guys I
just name
Wow Taysom Hill is more physical and is
more durable than Cuyler Murray probably
doesn't have the same speed Taysom Hill
is more accurate than Lamar Jackson and
Josh Allen and I think is just as fast
and just as athletic and with the mind
of Sean Payton you build around Taysom
Hill I believe he's the guy that
replaces Drew Brees going forward
feeling hot right now I think the number
one law the number one priority is
making sure that Alvin Kamara can throw
a dump off pass pretty well because if
you can have taste some Hill and being
able to run out into the flats and Alvin
Kamara you never know if he's gonna
catch it or if he's gonna run it you
just got this crazy unpredictable insane
three-man offense with Michael Thomas
who that's tough to stop he is a beast
bro like watching him is a joy and I
really believe he's the guy I really
believe that Sean Payton is sitting
there going everyone thinks we're gonna
go with Teddy
Teddy's the backup well you know if
anything that this Andrew Luck thing now
a couple days we've had to process it
there can never be enough good
quarterbacks no NFL no right it's it's
never enough to say hey we got 32 good
quarterbacks this year that's pretty
cool no you need to have like 50 because
I want there to be a good quarterback
every Sunday for every team absolutely
and so watching the watching Raiders
Tampa Bay and it's it's Matt McCoy
Peterson versus Drew Stanton and you're
like and this determines a playoff seed
exactly all right now next stage I
notice some things this is from my
gamblers out there my betters out there
some scheduling starts to the season and
some betting things that interest me
nugget number one for week one the
Browns might get a dozen sacks I've
watched a lot of the Browns this
preseason and I've watched a lot of the
Titans and I want to tell you that
there's no matchup that looks more
delectable to me week one and the Browns
versus of the Titans number one defenses
always start the year faster than
offenses they can act quickly they can
go speed offenses are still working on
offensive line play always starts the
season awful holdings are getting called
every year defenses over offenses
because offense is about precision and
defense is about disruption and it's a
lot easier to disrupt things without an
insane amount of practice time so when
you add in the fact that the Titans
offensive line already stunk
and that Mariota or Tannehill whoever
plays is already chibi both of them I
love that yeah split quarterback
backfield sweet but then when you factor
in the fact that Taylor LaJuan is
suspended and it's Miles Garrett who
might be my vote for Defensive Player of
the Year he's in my top three and that
offensive line for the breath that
defensive line of Sheldon Richardson
larium I can't even say it I'm about on
Jovie
I'll look it up I'm sorry I apologize
Miles Garrett I mean they go too deep
it's incredible I believe that they
might get ten sacks in week one so if
you're betting it just it sounds like a
and and no offense has looked more
beautiful than the Baker Mayfield
offense what they have done in their 3
preseason games from an efficiency
standpoint he they've looked incredible
incredible I love the brows in Week one
I know a lot of people will too
but it's just something that I've been
seeing it's on you Mike Vrabel you got
to come up with some sort of like over
pursuit offense plays and get some
Derrick Henry in the flat action so my
other two though that one's a little bit
more obvious my other two that are a
little bit these are fade plays um
sellin chargers early on the Chargers D
could struggle early I know that people
are gonna look at their playing Jacoby
percent in the Colts and they're gonna
go they're gonna eat that alive they're
gonna be depressed I'm going the
opposite the Colts offensive line is one
of the best in the NFL yeah that's not
going to change and that doesn't change
their second game is at Detroit a team
that likes to pound the rock I'm seeing
right now with the Chargers that
the issues that I was worried about the
last few years I don't know if they're
fully fixed right now
in terms of not having a lot of depth at
d-line also you factor in the ich the
injuries to Derwin James
the injury to Russell oh [ __ ] they're
starting left tackle the fact that I
don't think Melvin Gordon's gonna go
right away I could see the charger
starting slow against Indy and Detroit
and the second ones at Detroit and I
might be fading the Chargers early in
this season there are also a team that
they're not really good at analytics
they're not really good at tape study
they started off a little bit slow last
year I'm fading the Chargers early in
this season
I think they'll eventually get these
guys back and be healthy but I'm worried
about them the other team that I'm
buying that I think a lot of people are
selling early on is Denver hmm they get
there at the Raiders Monday Night
Football game and historically they've
done very well against the Raiders and I
think the Broncos might have a top-five
front seven and nobody's talking about
it the pass rushers a Bradley chub and
Von Miller you could put that up against
anybody in the NFL that's right up there
with Bosa and Ingram that's right up
there with what they got in Cleveland
it's better than Minnesota and when you
factor in the fact that it's Vic Fangio
so he gets four months to prepare for
the Raiders who like the Raiders are
missing Gabe
Martin I think it is Gabe Watson
whatever that I think it's Gabe Watson
for the first eight weeks and the know
Antonio Brown to practice with and all
this Jon Gruden stuff like Vic Fangio is
gonna eat and then what's the second one
it's a home against the Bears Vic Fangio
former team who the [ __ ] is going to
know how to stop Nagi's offense more
than Vic Fangio he's been watching them
in practice for the last two three years
he's going to know all of Travis keys
weaknesses and he's going to attack them
it's a Fangio revenge game and denver at
home in september is one of the locks
you should always make because of the
what's it called the air the altitude
altitude a chronic denver has
historically an incredible advantage in
september at home because teams are not
used to it
I think Denver might sneakily start off
the season two and oh and catch people
buy a lot of surprised now you asked me
to poke holes in your thoughts okay
number one I don't buy the whole oh he
used to coach over here so now he's
gonna be able to tell all the secrets
yes I'm sure he knows some of the
strengths and weaknesses sure but I
think Matt naggy knows that Vic Fangio
is preparing him for all the stuff that
he you know anything like they may get
over them to is though a lot of times
where I go with season-long predictions
and game predictions is who's the better
coach and I believe that McVicker Fangio
is a better defensive coach than Matt
naggy is an offensive coach mhm
maggie is a top eight offensive coach in
the NFL fan shares a top three that's a
very different argument and I respect
yeah I just I I don't like overreacting
to the like hey you know Danny Amendola
he's on the Dolphins now so he's gonna
be able to tell you coaches are
different I know yeah
people do tend to get a really excited
about that stuff of former coach when
Bill Belichick signs the tight end that
was cut from the team I don't buy into
that but but like I watched Kyle
Shanahan tear up his old defensive
coordinators that he was on the same
scheme Shannon does tear up a lot of
Defense's and I I would argue that Vic
Fangio shuts down a lot of people that
he's played with yeah so it's more of I
think Vic Fangio has watched Mitchell
try Biscay for two or three years and he
knows everything that that [ __ ]
doesn't like right and so it's more of
you know me man I love me some Vic and
so it's again you're poking holes
because there's holes to be poked yeah
I'm taking I'm taking unsubstantiated
take I like it just I'm doing my dutiful
Duty over here because it is my duty to
go against the grain because every year
there's some team that starts to and oh
and we go that happen oh my god last
year I called it with the Bucks because
the Bucks always play the Saints really
well if it's always great September
you go to Tampa Bay in September and
it's 94 degrees yeah that's how you lose
but people forget that [ __ ] playing in
Denver playing in Miami playing in Tampa
early in the year is an insane advantage
and we forget about it when we start
picking these games so I'm just trying
to get ahead of it and the other game
that you mentioned was Denver versus
Oakland do we have any data on how teams
that just came off of a hard knock
season do against the spread and week
one because that's got to be exhausting
to have cameras in your face 38 hours a
day keep going on that though I just do
think it's an interesting thing
obviously the numbers are gonna be
skewed and they might not mean anything
but I write very curious for someone
like Oakland Raiders who oh god there's
just been a lot of media a lot of stuff
in their face I mean as you just
mentioned athletes are people too and
the team's overall they've got to be
just so ready for the season to start
yeah go ahead oh no no I was just gonna
say that in the four five six in the
last 16 times that the Broncos have
played the Raiders the Broncos are 11
and 5 huh so they've had their number 2
yeah and so I just a lot of people get
very excited about the Raiders people
are gonna go Joe Flacco how [ __ ]
boring and I'm gonna go von Miller and
Bradley Chubb are gonna be incredible so
I'm just go wins football games he does
he does alright so my other seven my
other two takeaways from the seven
takeaways our defensive young studs that
I'm just noticing holy [ __ ] sure number
one is on your Patriots team Jay's
vinovich is going to be a star and it's
gonna be annoying and he already looks
like the next Clay Matthews
he's got the salad and it's this figure
this out and it's the look Oh Luke
Wilson all that stuff year the salad but
I'm watching him in the preseason games
look unblockable yeah he is and it's it
could be called a lazy comparison he
looks like the Ning kovitch he looks
like the Matthews he looks like the
effort pass rusher that's white I get it
I got a little Richard Seymour vibe
because I know
you said daryl morey likes to have when
you do athlete comparison you don't know
about that because Richard Seymour was a
mountain of a man
yes vinovich is actually a lot more
shifty than I would give him credit for
like he is quick yeah he's got some
strength to him but like more
importantly the [ __ ] fast and
he is going to be heat he's gonna be the
Jabal sheered I think he's more than
jabal sheer than he has the nick of it
I'll take that and really quick around
the edge vinovich might get eight sacks
this year like I wouldn't say no to that
I know like overall angry that the
Patriots got yet another guy you're
excited about and you wish was on the
Eagles uh no no it's not about that
I'm I don't get angry anymore about the
Patriots I get impressed that when they
draft they're not always great but when
they hit they really hit like this
Jacoby Meyers kid that you guys uh so
exciting seven threes everything that's
why and I know I'm recording this and it
might get outdated because Jadeveon
Clowney could get traded at any point by
the way I'm fully expecting a lot of
trades to happen on Labor Day weekend
this is the trade where this is the
weekend where Khalil Mack got traded
there was going to be a lot of guys that
are getting cut that teams are gonna be
like let's get some picks for this like
the Eagles got Darren Sproles a few
years ago I liked your theory though
that Jadeveon Clowney is gonna be traded
because some GM is gonna be showing off
he's gonna be flexing in a barbecue yeah
he's gonna be like hey you know what I'm
I can do because I'm the GM of whatever
team like Bruce Allen watch this I can
make a text boom now we have G Davey and
clowny on our roster Bruce sounds like
with his high school friend hasn't seen
is I like this theory oh man like what
does the last thing you did you say uh
you want me to get Jadeveon Clowney
right now and then he like pops open to
be like while he's playing cornhole like
he throws a Miss by the way just got
clowny
and then like dunks and all and he's
like God Oh cuz it no it starts because
one of his high school buddies is like
hey I just made partner in my law firm
he's like hey that's pretty cool watch
this I have Jadeveon Clowney on my team
now I love that that's why everything
happens on Labor Day weekend though this
is the only explanation I will say
though that a lot of times if if coaches
will work holidays and stuff but they
like every
thus they want to get all their [ __ ]
done so that they can have some time at
home if they have time at home right and
a lot of times we're we're getting ready
to make our end-of-the-year cuts they
got to go from 90 to 53 and so they're
looking over and they're going I got
surplus here at wide receiver
I got surplus here at offensive line
maybe we can move somebody right now and
so they go home and they get a little
separated from work and they're sitting
there in there and they read a tweet or
they see something on NFL Network and
they say generating clowny is on the
trading block like [ __ ] man I could
really use your Davian clowny and money
what do I need Nelson a galore for this
Jo white sighs doing really maybe I will
float him out there I totally think
that's a thing or it's more not what do
I need Nelson toggle or words what do I
need the fifth round pick in three years
when I might not even be working here
then like what do I need that for I am a
huge fan of like the other thing too
about trading for Jadeveon Clowney that
I hope it happens is if you trade like
let's say Washington says we don't think
Trenton Williams is gonna happen let's
trade them there and we get you David
Clowney
and then the fans go but what if he
leaves after a year well the way it
currently works with the compensatory
pick process is that Jadeveon Clowney
leaves after a year and then goes in
signs with another team you're gonna get
a third-round pick back so really what
you're doing is you're trading Trent
Williams who wasn't gonna play for you
you've got a year of Jadeveon Clowney
plus you get a third-round pick in two
years yeah so you are getting something
for him but if Trent Williams signs
anywhere you're just getting a
third-round pick but he's not playing
this year so if the Eagles were to trade
Nelson Aguilar who they're probably
going jjr thing a Whiteside could fit in
right there or Mack Hollins and we're
getting a third-round pick in two years
it's training if you're getting the
value back itself yeah the compensatory
pick process you're getting a
third-round pick four jenavian clowny
and I think it's gonna happen and if you
ask the Toronto Raptors what is it like
what if he leaves after a year and still
be a really good year you wouldn't trade
that for anything would you trade Jacoby
Myers for JIT for gtav and cloudy and as
you have Josh Gordon
Adelman Sony Michel de may-ya-yo believe
um no but I also I was thinking about
could they trade Damaris Thomas back to
the Texans but I don't think the Texans
would trade I I would I would want to
talk to because in this case I'm the GM
of the Patriots so I would go first
thing I would do is I would go to Tom
Brady and I would say is this gonna be
one of your guys this year because if
Tom says I like Jacoby I like this kid
he's doing he and I are clicking he's
gonna be my buddy I want his locker
right next to mine I'm not trading him
for gold but if he's like yeah you know
what I'll be fine with Julian let's
let's run it back with Julian and and
all I and Josh Gordon and we'll just see
how it goes but you know what I would
love to have Jadeveon Clowney on this
team man who would the the team that I'm
sure has called but I doubt it's gonna
work is the Vikings offering up laQuan
Treadwell okay for Jadeveon Clowney they
put them on the books on the the trading
block because they definitely gonna sign
them and the Vikings have a huge depth
issue as they always do on their
defensive line
I just don't think Letran laQuan
Treadwell is gonna get it done but I
look at your team too and I look at your
D line and while I do love I do like the
Danny Shelton's and the Adam Butler's
and I do like the Mike panels and the
Lauren skies and the Dietrich wises the
only guy that I really love on your D
line is Michael Bennett and I look at
your David Clowney at I mean you lost
Trey flowers
you lost Malcolm Brown there's a lot of
guys that have been rotational guys for
the Patriots but if they were able to
get clowny and I look at your wide
receivers I would trade Dorsett for
cloudy there's that yeah sure you've
gone but but I'm looking but I'm looking
at your guys like if you went into the
league if let's say you traded Jacoby
Myers if you went in with Dorsett Gordon
Edelman Demaryius Thomas and Nikhil
Harry
Braxton Barrios you can get that done
you can make that happen
yeah but if Jacoby Meyers is the guy I I
could see them trade in Phillip Dorsett
and you haven't even mentioned the
inevitable guy off the bills practice
squad that we're gonna grab at some
point in October and he's gonna have six
more touchdowns um the only other note
that I want to say wasn't part of my
seven it's just something to think about
is one thing that I would like to do
this season is a thing that I want to
call thought theft which is I am NOT the
artists man that's ever covered the NFL
and I'm not afraid to look at other
people covering the NFL and steal their
thoughts and even if you were the
smartest person to cover the NFL you
would be smarter than everyone else's
takes on the plan Sean McVeigh is still
stealing plays from other people yeah
and I heard my former co-host mr. sim
say the packers might end up having a
top five defense this year and it
clicked because I write down every news
story that's coming on I charge injuries
in my books because I'm looking for
trends an article just came out this
week that said when Clay Matthews went
in to go talk to the Packers he was
expecting away I just had a third kid
how are you gonna extend and they
instead told him we don't have room for
you last week over the weekend the
Packers released Josh Jones a
second-round pick from last year so in
one offseason they told an all-time
great we don't have room for you and
before everybody made their cuts they
were confident enough to cut a former
second-round pick which usually would
cause an uproar on a fan base going
oh you failed they're so confident in
their defense they're willing to get rid
of these people
I'm just putting all these things
together with the fact that Mike
penton's been good the Green Bay Packers
defense could be really scary this year
because it fits an analysis analyst that
I trust with teams showing you the depth
is [ __ ] crazy right now and when you
look at them and you see Darnell Savage
and Adrian Amos and Kevin king and gyre
Alexander and trauma and Brown and Tony
Brown in the secondary and then you look
at their edge rushers was a Darius Smith
and Preston Smith and we saw with rashon
Gary and what he could be as a
first-round pick and Cuyler fakher all
now being the fourth or fifth guy not
the first with Kenny Clark in the middle
with montre vyas Adams this Green Bay
Packers defense everyone's talking about
could Matt Lafleur's
offense work with Aaron Rodgers they
might not need 35 points they might need
25 mm-hmm
I like it I dig it so for me it's it's
taking taking a thought that I went oh I
haven't heard that thought and then
going is there any clues that no one's
paying attention to teams that cut guys
now before the massive cuts or [ __ ]
deepest [ __ ] and they feel comfortable
making that and they're like I don't
need to wait I'm fine making this I feel
super cool doing it we always say isn't
it nice when a team gives a player more
than ample time to test the market the
only teams that are willing to do that
are the teams that are a little bit
cocky mm-hmm everyone else is like I
don't know who should we cut let's wait
till the day yeah so is the the Green
Bay Packers are you leaning toward them
for annecy north are you on a wait find
out
Thursday's pod can cause a tease it is
called a tease so on Thursday's podcast
we're gonna do the playoff teams we are
gonna do some awards I am going to with
all of my picks let you know what the
the lines are in case you want to bet
them I've already told you my bets
though for the season and we will be
announcing the co-hosts hopefully on
Thursday because next week it's first
week of the year meant yeah it's
happening holy crap Labor Day weekend
exciting it's so exciting
you know nothing stops for the NFL
season it's coming whether whether
you're ready for it or not
and then next Wednesday first episode of
ditch the playbook oh yeah watch it get
on the VR app all right I love you guys
very much I hope you guys enjoyed this
show
I love Andrew Luck good good life man
yeah go and and and live like you've
never lived before go and hug one of the
people you love if you haven't hugged
him in a while don't become an analyst
in the NFL if you do that I'm pissed and
if you're on a two-lane highway don't be
the same speed as the car next to you
just don't do that have you done that
one before
no of course not no I mean have you
given that advice know that your parting
wisdom oh we were on the road for about
eight hours on Friday don't drive in the
same Lane I am Anna lefke holla holla
holla Nick run an audio appreciate you
Jake on the edit you're the [ __ ] man
I'll talk to you guys later
be well
[Music]